hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and by the end of
this video you will know everything you
need to know about all the different
breathing Styles in Demon Slayer
including the strongest breathing Styles
demonic variations of breathing Styles
and how each style emerged who uses it
and what its unique powers are if you
want to show off to all your friends
that you know more about Demon Slayer
than them you've come to exactly the
right place so drop a quick like
subscribe and let's get into it
breathing styles are unique
swordsmanship techniques used by members
of the Demon Slayer core these tiles are
inspired by a specific element or
substance such as a flame or water or
stone and these styles are used in
combination with a nichiren blade in
order to kill demons demon Slayers
usually use swords equipped with
nitrogen blades but some use other types
of weapons like an ax or a Cleaver but
regardless of the type of weapon they
have to be made with with nature in
blades if demons are cut with a regular
blade they will not die I actually made
a video about all the breathing Styles
and Demon Slayer almost four years ago
but that was before we had all the
updated information and in fact we
didn't even have the official
translations for many of the forms now
is the perfect time to make a full
updated video that contains all the
latest up-to-date information as I
mentioned in that previous video each
breathing style focuses around specific
breathing patterns which enables the
users to strengthen their bodies by
increasing their lung capacity and the
flow of oxygen in their blood this
allows the users to perform incredible
feeds including superhuman movements and
techniques making it possible for the
demon stairs to take on the demons even
though demons are generally much
stronger and much more resilient than
regular humans now the concept of
breathing Styles in Demon Slayer did not
come out of nowhere breathing techniques
are a crucial aspect of real-life
martial arts and the further you advance
in martial arts the more focus is placed
on proper breathing as well as on things
like presence and spirit which are also
things that are covered in Demon's air
but does this mean that by training
martial arts with a sword you will
eventually become as strong as yorichi
in real life probably not but I do like
the fact that the battle system in Demon
Slayer takes a lot of inspiration from
Real Life Martial Arts like iaido and
Kendo speaking of yorichi the first
breathing style appeared nearly 500
years ago and the name of this breathing
style is Sun breathing but before we get
into all the juicy info I have to warn
you that this video will contain manga
spoilers in terms of the breathing
Styles I'm covering everything we know
about all of them so please proceed with
caution you have been warned Sun
breathing was created by yorichi
tsugikuni the strongest Demon Slayer in
history and it seems to be something
that just came to him naturally that's
because yorichi was born with
unbelievable powers and incredible
levels of natural Talent he was an
absolute Prodigy someone born with the
kind of talented potential that the rest
of us can only dream of he was born with
his Demon Slayer Mark already manifested
he was also born with the ability to see
into the transparent world and his
physical strength speed and endurance
was on a whole other level from normal
people yorichi believed that he was born
into this world with all those special
abilities because his Destiny was to
defeat the progenitor of all the demons
muza it was like the universe itself was
trying to balance itself out by creating
a creature who could stop the
overpowered muzon after his own wife an
unborn child were killed by a demon
while he was away from home yorichi
joined the Demon Slayer core this is
when he developed what came to be known
as Sun breathing and he tried to teach
this breathing style to other demon
Slayers including to his own twin
brother michikatsu but the other demon
Slayers simply weren't as strong and as
talented as yorichi so they were never
able to master Sun breathing as a result
yorichi changed the way he taught them
in order to adapt his breathing style to
their own individual skills and
abilities and this is how the derivative
Styles appeared including water
breathing flame breathing wind breathing
Stone breathing and so on they all
emerged out of sun breathing but they
are imperfect interpretations of sun
Breathing by individual demon Slayers
who just couldn't match the Superhuman
strength and skill of yorichi as the
original style perfected by yorichi
himself Sun breathing was the strongest
of all the Styles but because no one but
yorichi could Master it it essentially
died out after his death however the
fundamentals of sun breathing were
preserved in the form of a ritual dance
performed by the head of the Commodore
family a dance known as hinokami kagura
about 450 years ago yorichi said the
life of tanjiro's ancestors sumioshi and
his wife yorichi and sumioshi became
friends and eventually yorichi
demonstrated all the forms of sun
breathing to sumiyoshi tanjiro's
ancestor then learned all the forms and
passed them on to his son in the form of
the hinokami kagura ritual dance this
was repeated from generation to
generation until it eventually reached
tanjiro himself at first Sun breathing
has 12 known forms these include dance
which is a single high-powered slash
that comes down in an arc Clear Blue Sky
a circular spinning slash that sees the
user rotate their upper body to cut at a
full 360 Degrees Raging Sun an attack
composed of a vertical slash followed by
a horizontal slash burning bones Summer
Sun a single spiraling slash that has
both offensive and defensive properties
Setting Sun transformation in which the
user performs a backflip and that
unleashes a single horizontal slash with
the intention of taking off his
opponent's head solar heat Haze in which
the user rushes forward while hidden in
a heat Haze this Haze hides the true
size and position of the user's sword
allowing them to deliver a surprise
attack then there's beneficent Radiance
where the user spirals upwards into the
air and performs a swirling upwards
slash sunflower thrust a single thrust
that uses the tip of the sword to attack
the target Dragon Sun halo dance which
involves the user delivering a bunch of
consecutive slashes in continuous motion
allowing him to strike and decapitate
multiple targets at once Firewheel
involves the user spinning through the
air in order to get behind the opponent
and then deliver a vertical slash in a
circular motion fake rainbow is a
defensive technique that allows the user
to dodge quickly using rapid twists and
rotations this technique will actually
leave after images and confuse opponents
the last of the 12 initial forms is
called Flame dance which is a
combination of two strikes that starts
off with a vertical slash and then
immediately leads into a second
horizontal slash now initially whenever
tanjiro was using hinokamikagura he was
simply repeating the forms as they were
taught to him by his father but after
being knocked out during an important
battle tanjiro is able to see the
memories of his ancestors sumioshi
directly and he realizes that some of
the intricacies of the 12 forms of sun
breathing were lost to time in other
words the hinokamikagura that he learned
from his father was not the perfected
version of sun breathing tanjiro fully
Masters all 12 forms after seeing
sumioshi's memories of yorichi actually
performing all the sun breathing forms
himself tanjiro then perfects the forms
by adjusting the position of his body as
well as his movements and breathing this
makes tanjiro a lot stronger and more
effective in battle and it also allows
him to discover the secret third 18th
form of sun breathing the 13th form was
devised by yorichi for the specific
purpose of defeating muzan by rapidly
and continuously performing all 12 forms
of sun breathing the user is able to
destroy all 12 of muzons of vital organs
his seven hearts and five brains which
are dispersed throughout his demonic
body tanjiro's ability to perfect
sunbreathing and unlock the secret 13th
form is key to defeating muzon now let's
talk about water breathing the first
breathing style that we are formally
introduced to in the story because it is
the first breathing style that tanjiro
learns when he decides to become a Demon
Slayer water breathing is one of the
original derivatives of sun breathing
and it is said that there has always
been a water hashira and a flame hashira
in every generation from the days of
yorichi to the present day water
breathing is a swordsmanship style that
is inspired by the movements of water
and a special emphasis is placed on
creating fluid motion on being flexible
and on adapting to any and all
situations just like water instantly
adjusts its flow no matter what obstacle
appears in its way water breathing
appears to be the most common breathing
style as it seems to be one of the
easiest styles to teach newcomers known
users of water breathing include the
current water hashira giyu tomioka the
former water hashira sakonji urokodaki
tanjiro kamado aoi kanzaki murata sabito
and makomo water breathing has 10
regular forms and then there's an 11th
form that giyu himself created and that
only giyu is able to perform the forms
include first form water surface slash
which is a single concentrated slash the
second form is water wheel which
involves the user jumping in the air and
spinning in midair in a circular path in
order to create an attack that resembles
a water wheel the third form is Flowing
dance which involves the user swinging
their sword while mimicking the
movements of flowing
otter the fourth form is striking tide
which involves the user performing
multiple consecutive slashes while
twisting his or her body in a way that
resembles a powerful water tide the
fifth form is blessed rain after the
drought which allows the user to kill
the Target in a merciful way so that the
enemy will not suffer this is used on
enemies who are already defeated and
helpless the sixth form is Whirlpool
which involves the user sharply twisting
their upper and lower body and creating
a Whirlpool that will cut through
anything in its path the seventh form is
drop Ripple thrust the fastest technique
of the breath of water style it amounts
to a single but very quick and accurate
stab the eighth form is waterfall Basin
a vertical cut the ninth form is
splashing water flow turbulent which
allows the user to adapt to shaky
footing by minimizing his Landing time
and the size of the surface needed to
land safely the 10th form is constant
flux a continuous slashing attack that
becomes more powerful with each new
rotation finally the 11th form is gyu's
own custom form called dead kong this
form allows the user to essentially go
Ultra instinct Kyu calms his body
perfectly and enters a completely
peaceful State he then blocks deflects
and cuts all attacks with pure Instinct
without needing to even think about it
next let's talk about flame breathing
which just like water breathing has been
represented in every hashira generation
since the time of yorichi like water
breathing flame breathing is derived
directly from Sun breathing but unlike
water breathing it is a style that is
inspired by the movements and power of
flames flame breathing is more
aggressive than water breathing and a
greater emphasis is placed on decisive
powerful attacks that overwhelm the
opponent like scorching flames it's less
about flexibility and going with the
flow and more about burning your
opponent with the flame that rages
inside you known users of flame
breathing include the former flame
hashira shinjurorengoku and the current
flame hashira kyojira rengoku well
current at the beginning of the story
The Love hashira mitsuri kanroji is also
a user of flame breathing but she
eventually developed her own derivative
style Called Love breathing but we'll
talk more about that later flame
breathing has nine different forms but
only six are known to us these include
first form unknowing fire an attack that
involves the user charging their
opponent and Swinging their Blade with
the intent to decapitate the enemy
second form Rising scorching sun which
is an upward slash attack third form
blazing Universe which is an arched
vertical downward slash fourth form
blooming flame undulation which involves
the user spinning their sword rapidly in
order to defend from enemy attacks fifth
form flame tiger which involves multiple
sword slashes that form the shape of a
tiger and finally ninth form rengoku a
fiery Slash from a distance that has the
power to obliterate everything in sight
the ninth form is said to be unique to
members of the rengoku family I would
love to know more about the first flame
breathing user and other users
throughout history but unfortunately
shinjiro the father of kyojiro destroyed
the generational flame hasha record of
the rengoku family nevertheless we do
know that the very first user of flame
breathing who learned it from yorichi
himself five centuries ago had a very
similar hairstyle and hair color to
kyojuro and this implies that flame
breathing has always been passed on
within the rengoku family from the very
beginning it's even possible that every
flame hashira was a member of the
rengoku clan then we have wind breathing
which is also derived directly from Sun
breathing and which is inspired by the
movements of the wind including
whirlwinds wind gusts and torrents wind
breathing is a heavily offensive reading
style that seeks to overwhelm opponents
with the fast wild and unrelenting force
of a windstorm there are only two known
users of wind breathing including the
current wind hashira sanami shinazugawa
and masachika kumeno Sanam friend and
the man who recruited him into the Demon
Slayer core wind breathing has nine
known forms including first form dust
Whirlwind cutter which involves the user
rushing his opponent with great speed
and unleashing a cyclone of Sword
slashes second form claws purifying wind
an attack that unleashes four vertical
slashes in the shape of a claw that cut
into the enemy third form a clean storm
wintry which involves the user creating
a whirlwind of slashes around themselves
allowing him to defend himself against
enemy attacks and cut up everything in
his immediate surroundings fourth form
Rising dust storm an upward swing of the
sword from multiple directions fifth
form Cold Mountain wind a multi-pronged
arched strike from above sixth form
blackwind Mountain Mist which involves
the user rotating their body in order to
create a powerful upward slashing
tornado seventh form Gale sudden gusts
which involves the user jumping into the
air while swinging his sword creating
gale force winds that cut through the
opponent 8th form primary Gale slash
another attack where the user leaps into
the air and swings the sword this time
the user swings The Sword in such a way
as to create circular wind torrents that
slice up the opponent finally we have
ninth form idaten typhoon which involves
the user doing backflips through the air
and unleashing Powerful circular slashes
while upside down these slashes will
shred everything that is located below
the user now let's talk about Stone
breathing yet another breathing style
that is derived directly from Sun
breathing this style is inspired by the
Earth and stone and its techniques rely
on the earth beneath the user's feet to
make the users stance and forms as firm
and sturdy as possible Stone breathing
is good for both offense and defense and
it emphasizes the importance of physical
strength firm balance perfect awareness
of your surroundings and a sturdy Battle
Stance although we know that other other
Stone breathing users existed in the
past the only user of stone breathing
known to us is the stone hashirak
yomejima kyome's fighting style is
unique because he doesn't use a nitin in
Katana in battle instead he uses a
nitroen chain the spike flail and ax
Stone breathing has five known forms
including first form Serpentine bipolar
which involves the user throwing both
his ax and flail at his opponent at the
same time and then pulling on the chain
in order to make both weapons rotate and
drill through the enemy second form
upper smash which involves the user
throwing the ax and flail at his Target
in order to create a pincer attack the
user can then Smash down on the chain
and force it to rebound on the target
third form stone skin which is a
defensive technique involving a barrage
of slashes designed to deflect enemy
attacks fourth form volcanic rock rapid
Conquest a two-pronged attack from a
distance that involves spinning the ax
and spiked flail on the chain in order
to strike the opponent from a distance
finally there's fifth form arcs of
justice for which the user unleashes a
massive barrage of strikes with the
flail and ax this is also a two-pronged
attack that is designed to inflict a
huge amount of damage next up let's talk
about thunder breathing the fifth
breathing style that is derived directly
from Sun breathing Thunder breathing is
of course inspired by thunder and
lightning and it focuses on extremely
quick movements and attacks that are
reminiscent of lightning strikes
incredible speed is the thing that
really sets Thunder breathing apart from
the other styles so much so that tanjiro
actually incorporates aspects of
zenitu's Thunder breathing into his own
Sun breathing there are three known
users of Thunder breathing including
zenitsu zenitu's master gigoro kuajima
who is a former Thunder hashira and
finally kaigaku who is gigoro's other
disciple along with zenitsu as we know
there is no Thunder hashira in the
current hashira generation but there
certainly were multiple Thunder hashira
in the past Thunder breathing has seven
known forms including first form
Thunderclap and Flash which allows the
user to move and Slash the opponent with
Incredible thunderous speed because this
is the only form that zenitsu is capable
of using at first he does his best to
master it and maximize its Effectiveness
as a result zenitu learns how to perform
this technique 6 and even 8 times in
Rapid succession and zenitsu is also
able to augment the speed of this form
as he strives to bring out its full
potential leading to his ultimate attack
Thunderclap and Flash godspeed the
second form is called rice spirit and it
involves the user unleashing five
separate lightning slashes performed in
a single moment the third form is
buzzing Thunder swarm a spinning wave of
lightning that explodes in all
directions the fourth form is distant
Thunder which allows the user to create
a thunderous strike from a distance the
fifth form is heat lightning a slashing
attack infused with lightning that can
burn the flesh the sixth form is Rumble
and Flash which is a series of
long-range strikes capable of cracking
the enemy's body the seventh and final
form is called flaming Thunder God and
this form is actually developed by
zenitsu himself later on in the story it
allows the user to rush forward at
blinding speed and launch a devastating
forward slash at his opponent when this
attack is used it appears as if a
Lightning Dragon is emerging from The
Sword and now we come to our first
demonic mutation of a breathing style
you see zenitsu's Master's other
disciple kaigaku was a user of Thunder
breathing who willingly decided to
become a demon he eventually attained
the rank of upper moon 6. now here's the
interesting thing about kaigaku once he
becomes a demon he still uses thunder
breathing but he also develops a blood
demon art which allows him to actually
create and manipulate real lightning as
he fights when a human uses a breathing
style their movements are merely
inspired by whichever element there
style is based on so a flame breathing
user isn't actually producing Flames the
Flames we see are just an artistic
representation of what the moves are
inspired by but a breathing style user
who also has real Supernatural demonic
powers can essentially create a new and
improved breathing style that
incorporates both swordsmanship
techniques and actual Supernatural
Powers so when kaikaku becomes a demon
he is able to combine his Thunder
breathing with actual Black Lightning
which he can use to attack his opponents
and burn their bodies during the fight
all of his thunder-breathing forms
become more deadly and more powerful and
his range and speed are also greatly
increased due to his demonic Powers the
change that a breathing style undergoes
when it is combined with a blood demon
art is massive and I think it deserves a
special classification demon kagaku's
Thunder breathing isn't just regular
Thunder breathing it is demonic Thunder
breathing and it is an entirely
different beast in fact most of the
Thunder breathing forms that we know
forms two through six have only ever
been shown as being performed by demon
kaigaku that's because then it's only
ever learned the first form and then
later on in the story he created the
seventh this means that forms two
through six have only been performed in
combination with kaikaku's blood demon
art and if they had been performed by a
normal human they actually would have
looked different and since we're on the
topic of breathing styles that are
eventually transformed into demonic
breathing Styles we have to talk about
Moon breathing and its sole user upper
Moon one kokushibo now officially the
Demon Slayer core believes that there
are only five different breathing styles
that were derived directly from Sun
breathing and those five are the ones
we've talked about already but the truth
is that there is a sixth and that is
Moon breathing as far as we know Moon
breathing has only ever been used by one
man kokushibo this might be why most
people don't even realize that the style
exists the only man who ever used it
became a demon like 450 years ago so the
knowledge of its existence was probably
lost to time as a human kokushiba was
actually the twin brother of yorichi he
was michikatsu tsugikuni and he learned
his breathing style directly from his
brother Moon breathing is inspired by
the shape of the Crescent Moon with a
focus on Fast and Powerful
crescent-shaped attacks that combine
both offensive and defensive elements
during his human life kokujiba was a
demon Slayer and he was arguably the
second strongest Demon Slayer after his
brother yorichi but kokushi became
jealous of his brother when he realized
that no matter how hard he trained he
would never be able to surpass him so he
accepted muzan's proposal to become a
demon so that he could use demon powers
to finally surpass his brother Moon
breathing has at least 16 forms but
we've only seen 11 of them in action
it's important to note that all the
forms we see kokushiba perform are done
in conjunction with his blood demon art
which allows him to actually create
Crescent Moon shaped blades that are
constantly changing in length and size
making it incredibly difficult to
predict the range of his attacks these
Crescent blades are separate from his
sword and are like deadly flying
boomerangs that attack hokushiba's
opponents as he fights them in other
words we've never actually seen regular
Moon breathing in action only demonic
Moon breathing the forms of moon
breathing include first form Dark Moon
evening Palace which involves the user
quickly drawing his sword performing a
swift single slash movement that creates
several crescent-shaped blades and then
sheathing his sword again the second
form is called pearl flower Moon gazing
and it involves the user performing
three rapid slashes that release a bunch
of Crescent blades at the opponent then
we have third form loath some Moon
chains which involves two wide
crescent-shaped slashes which create a
barrage of Crescent blades fifth form
Moon Spirit calamitous Eddie which
involves the user layering multiple
curved slashes one over the other
creating a Vortex of crescent moon
blades sixth form Perpetual night lonely
Moon incessant which again involves the
user swiftly performing a bunch of
curved slashes and this releases an
entire Salvo of Crescent blades seventh
form mirror of Misfortune moonlit which
involves the user launching a forward
Crescent shaped slash that unleashes
additional slashes which expand outward
in advance on the opponent 8th form moon
dragon ringtail which involves using his
special demonic Katana to perform a huge
card Slash from a distance which again
generates a whole bunch of Crescent
blades ninth form waning moon swaths
which involves kokushi by using his
special demon Katana to unleash multiple
curved slashes that leave a whole bunch
of Crescent blades along the path that
the sword follows 10th form drilling
slashes Moon through bamboo leaves
involves kokushiba using his demon sword
to create three circular slashes that
look like Saws and it also generate a
bunch of Crescent blades along their
path 14th form catastrophe 10 mon
Crescent Moon involves the user
performing curved slashes one after the
other these slashes then expand in all
directions and become larger generating
a Vortex of Crescent blades all around
the user finally the last known form is
16th form moonbow Half Moon which
involves the user swinging his demonic
sword upwards and then launching six
curved slashes down at the ground
leaving craters in the places they
connected with the ground round forms 4
11 12 13 and 15 also exist but they are
not revealed in the story 16 is the most
forms out of any breathing style that
we've seen but it makes sense that
kokushipo's breathing style would have
so many different forms because he had
literally 450 years to create and
perfect them all and now that we've
covered all the breathing styles that
were directly derived from Sun breathing
let's talk about the derivatives of the
derivatives styles that were derived out
of the six tiles that came from Sun
breathing some of these derivatives of
derivatives were created in order to
accommodate the special physical
structure and ability of their users as
was the case with mitsuri and love
breathing While others were created to
accommodate for certain physical
limitations of the user as was the case
with shinobu and insect breathing but
let's start things off with the
derivatives of water breathing because
there are actually three of them well
two direct derivatives flower and
serpent breathing and then a third
generation derivative insect breathing
which is actually derived from flower
breathing serpent breathing is used by
The Serpent hashira obanai iguro and he
is the only known user of this style
this style is inspired by the slithering
movements of a snake and igoro actually
has a unique custom sword with a blade
that twists like a slithering snake this
allows for unpredictable attacks that
wind from side to side before ultimately
connecting with the target when the
target least expects it this focus on
winding movements is reminiscent of
water breathing which focuses on the
flow of water but serpent breathing has
its own unique forms these include first
form winding serpent slash which
involves the user moving in a snake-like
way while unleashing a bunch of winding
slashes second form Venom fangs of the
narrow head which involve the user
getting behind the enemy using
incredible speed and relieving them of
their head third form coil choke which
involves the user circling his targets
while slicing at them from all
directions for fourth form twin-headed
reptile which involves the user jumping
in the air and releasing a horizontal
slash that cuts through the enemy then
finally fifth form slithering serpent
which involves the user making wild
curving movements with their specially
designed sword allowing the user to
relieve multiple Demons of their heads
in a single attack next let's talk about
the other known derivative of water
breathing which is flower breathing this
style is used by kanae kocho the older
sister of shinabukocho and the former
flower hashira as well as by kanawo
tsuri this style is inspired by flowers
and other types of plants and it focuses
on graceful technically sophisticated
attacks and on the user's own agility
users of this breathing style are also
able to boost their sense of sight but
if they overdo this ability they can
lose their sight altogether there are
five known forms of flower breathing
including second form honorable Shadow
Plum a series of rotating sword slashes
used defensively to deflect attacks
fourth form Crimson hanagoromo a single
slash of the sword that twists and
Curves in a graceful manner fifth form
peonies of futility a combo move that
features nine flowing consecutive
attacks sixth form whirling Peach an
invasion technique that allows the user
to quickly shift their weight and spin
towards the enemy thereby shifting
defense to attack and final form
equinoxidil Vermilion I a focusing
technique that raises the user's kinetic
Vision to its maximum power essentially
allowing the user to see everything in
slow motion while this can be extremely
useful in battle it is also a dangerous
technique because it puts a lot of
strain on the user's eyes and it can
lead to partial or complete blindness
and then there's insect breathing which
is a derivative of flower breathing
which is of course a derivative of water
breathing which is itself a derivative
of sun breathing you still with me okay
good insect breathing was invented by
the insect hashira shinabukocho in order
to accom her own petite body and lack of
upper body strength basically shinabu
does not have the physical strength to
behead a demon so she has to use a
special swordsmanship style that focuses
on stabbing thrusting and inflicting
shallow Cuts with a blade that is coated
with wisteria poison and this poison can
incapacitate demons the technique is
inspired by poisonous insects who can
inflict deadly poisonous things on much
larger and stronger opponents shinobu
also uses a custom sword that is smaller
and lighter than a normal Katana and a
small weight of her sword allows for
extra speed and maneuverability insect
breathing has four known forms including
butterfly dance capris a jumping attack
that slashes the opponent several times
in order to inject the opponent with
poison dance of the bee sting true
flutter an incredibly fast dash at the
opponent followed by a single thrusting
attack that injects the opponent with
poison dance of the dragonfly compound
eye hexagon a combo attack that strikes
the target six times in six different
different areas that are considered to
be weak spots within the body injecting
poison in each area in order to increase
the chances of the Enemy being
overwhelmed by poison finally we have
dance of the centipede hundred legged
zigzag which involves the user running
at full speed in a zigzag pattern
confusing the opponent and creating an
opening for a powerful poisonous thrust
now that we've covered all the
derivatives of water breathing let's
talk about the only known derivative of
flame breathing mitsuri's love breathing
mitsuri actually learned flame breathing
first and she learned it directly from
the former flame hashirak kyojirorengoku
eventually she altered the style so that
it would better suit her unique physical
structure including the fact that she
has superhuman flexibility and the
muscle density that is eight times
higher than normal her breathing style
is inspired by the emotion of love and
it focuses on flexibility agility and
dexterity mitsuri also uses a special
custom sword that functions more like a
sharp whip than a conventional Katana
because of her unique sword and
unconventional acrobatic abilities she
is a very unpredictable opponent love
breathing has five known forms including
first form Shivers of First Love an
attack that involves a rapid Dash
followed by multiple long-range
whip-like slashes second form love pangs
which unleashes multiple whip-like
slashes all around the user's body third
form cat love shower which involves the
user leaping into the air and then
releasing a rapid succession of ranged
attacks fifth form swaying love wild
claw which is a backward somersault
through the air that creates a long
string of whipping attacks and sixth
form cat-legged wings of love which
involves the user twirling upside down
and creating Helix shaped slashes that
can deflect enemy attacks next let's
talk about sound breathing which is a
derivative of Thunder breathing it is
used by the sound hashirat tengen uzui
and it is of course inspired by the
properties of sound this breathing style
focuses on speed and Loud explosive
attacks and it often relies on tengen's
superhuman sensor hearing similar to
echolocation tengen is capable of
deconstructing an opponent's movements
into bass sounds analyzing the sounds
and identifying openings and weaknesses
based on those sounds which he then
exploits tengen uses several
unconventional weapons including dual
nitrogen Cleavers that are held together
by a metal chain kind of like nunchucks
he also uses explosive beads that allow
him to detonate actual explosions in
battle and he uses kunai sound breathing
was designed to work with this specific
weaponry and so Tangen is the only one
who can use sound breathing techniques
there are three known forms of sound
breathing including first form Roar
which involves the user raising his
Cleavers above his head and slamming
them into the ground thereby creating
explosions that sound like thunder
fourth form constant resounding slashes
an attack that is both offensive and
defensive in nature and involves the
user spinning his swords while
simultaneously releasing bombs at his
targets and fifth form string
performance which involves the user
charging at his opponent while spinning
his swords on a chain while releasing
both a series of continuous slashes and
bombs at the same time the final two
breathing styles are both derivatives of
wind breathing the first is Mist
breathing which is used by the Mist
hashira muichiro tokito it is inspired
by the properties of mist and it focuses
on quick sudden attacks that are
stealthy and unpredictable as if they
were emerging from a thick Mist wichiro
actually wears exceptionally baggy
clothing so that his movements are
harder to read and predict missed
breathing has seven known forms
including first form low clouds distant
Haze which is a thrusting attack second
form eight-layered Mist which involves a
barrage of eight slashes one on top of
the other third form scattering Mist
Splash a circular slash with the power
to blow away enemy projectiles fourth
form shifting flow slash which includes
a rapid slash right as the sword is
pulled from its Scabbard fifth form sea
of clouds and Haze which involves the
user running at the enemy at high speed
and following through with a barrage of
slashes sixth form lunar dispersing Mist
which involves the user leaping into the
air and raining down a large number of
slashes on his enemies and finally
seventh form obscuring clouds which is a
technique that allows its user to
confuse his enemies by Shifting the
tempo of his movements in a way that
tricks the opponent's eyes this form was
created by muichiro himself the final
breathing style that we need to talk
about is Beast breathing which is also a
derivative of wind breathing this style
is used by the wild man himself inosuke
hashibira and he is the only known user
inosuke actually grew up in the
wilderness and was raised by wild boars
so his breathing style is inspired by
wild beasts and animals it focuses on
wild and ferocious animalistic attacks
inosuke uses dual Nigerian swords with
chips along the blade that look like the
sharp teeth of a beast and in also has a
superhuman sense of touch which he uses
to enhance his breathing techniques
Beast breathing has 11 known forms
including first Fang Piers which allows
the user to stab a target's neck
simultaneously with both of his blades
second Fang slice which allows the user
to slash at a target with both blades in
an X formation third Fang devour which
involves the user unleashing two
simultaneous horizontal slashes aimed at
an opponent's throat fourth Fang slice
and dice which is a flurry of diagonal
slices fifth Fang crazy cutting which is
a slicing attack that lashes out in all
directions around the user as he jumps
through the air sixth Fang Palisade bite
in which the user uses two swords to
launch two slashes at his opponent from
both directions essentially sawing at
them in an attempt to relieve them of
their head seventh Fang spatial
awareness which gives the user the
ability to send subtle changes in the
air across a wide area and this allows
the user to identify the locations of
his potential enemies in that area then
there's eighth Fang explosive Rush which
is basically inosuka just rushing his
enemies and Swinging both swords with
amazing speed ninth Fang extending bendy
slash which allows the user to dislocate
the joints on his arms in order to
extend the reach of his attack 10th Fang
whirling fangs which is a spinning
attack that cuts everything in sight
including enemy projectiles and 11th
Fang sudden throwing strike which is
basically those kid chucking both swords
at an enemy and that is it all 16
breathing Styles and demons are
explained including the original style
the six main derivatives the two demonic
breathing Styles the six derivatives of
derivatives and of course insect
breathing which is a derivative of a
derivative of a derivative if you're
looking for another epic Demon Slayer
video to watch next don't ignore our
breakdown of every single demon Moon and
their powers Link in the description and
on screen right now if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more demon
star content here on Channel leave a
quick like right now and if you're one
of the over 50 of people who watch our
videos but haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a massive favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications